let's say the united states economy is
going into a recession or maybe even
worse than a recession and you are the
chairman of the federal reserve and you
need to do something about it well the
first thing you would do is that you
would lower the federal funds rate and
that's the rate that banks lend to each
other overnight and the way that you
lower it if the banks don't do it on
their on their own after you say you
want to lower it is that you print money
you print money
as the federal reserve and you use it to
buy usually short-term treasury
securities and then that money gets
deposited in banks so the demand for
reserves because that's what these
things are the demand for reserves goes
down the supply goes up and the federal
funds rate should go down but what
happens if you keep doing this and you
keep lowering the federal funds rate all
the way down so that the overnight
borrowing rate is approximately
zero percent what do you do then if the
economy still looks like it's in a bit
of a tailspin
well you could still print money you
could still print money but using that
money to buy short-term debt won't help
any because you're not going to lower
the short-term overnight inter-bank
interest rate anymore so you can go out
and buy other things
you could buy
other things and those other things can
be longer term treasuries
longer term
treasuries or it could be other types of
securities it could be you could buy
mortgage-backed securities
mortgage-backed securities you could buy
commercial debt
commercial debt
and this idea of printing money not just
for target interest rate but essentially
to get that money into circulation and
maybe to affect other parts of the
market this is called quantitative
easing
quantitative
easing and in bernanke's mind although
that's exactly what he's doing he's
printing money to buy other things in
what the fed traditionally does when it
cares about the overnight borrowing rate
he calls it not necessarily quantitative
easing but credit easing and in his mind
even though mechanically they're the
same thing in his mind he's saying look
i'm printing this money not just for the
sake of the of printing the money and
putting it into circulation i'm printing
money so that i can buy particular
assets particular assets where it seems
like there might be a log jam in the
credit markets because with just
printing money and buying government
securities maybe the interest rates on
government debt goes down but maybe
because of panic or crisis interest or
the the prices on these things don't
behave properly so in order to fix that
credit easing in the in the bernanke
sense
would be to be would go out and buy this
type of asset